[Applause]
[Music]
look at this now it's a little more even
on ya strum of : yeah okay I'll tackle
this question how much of a role has
Congress's inability to function these
last two years played in slowing down
the recovery that's for you but of
course you could answer that too since
you're in Congress and it is something
Joe Biden raised last night that we were
hoping that Obama did and he just
totally let that pass unfortunately
during his 36 years things work really
well but it is an issue it's got the
uncertainty is this nobody knows what to
do with their money they're all just
sitting on the sidelines and the only
person that's doing anything has been
Bernanke he's pumping all this liquidity
into this system
West Point was you know they keep saying
Obama's policies have been work to him
and let him and have his policies
shockingly Toby had Congress House and
Senate for two years no we did a lot
step together Senate the first president
to have it practically in a lifetime
he absolutely did he ran through a
number of major pieces of legislation on
a purely partisan basis the fact is
giving people health care who need it
and then you know we can talk about all
these things but he did them he they
were his priorities he got them done and
this is where we are 7.0 plus whatever
the ruler two big things he got done I
can't really think about it the stimulus
and healthcare the stimulus almost every
economist says saved us from going out
to a depression he got out of the war in
Iraq we are not done in Iraq we simply
have gotten rid of our military maybe we
should've got away and lived in Saudi
Arabia six years my neighbor Iraq was
fighting a war with Iran and everybody
in the Middle East all of our allies and
some of them that aren't they all agree
on one thing the most dangerous player
in the neighborhood is Iran so as long
as a rock was fighting Iran you know the
enemy of your enemy is who okay it's
your friend and so when we went into
Iraq destabilized Iraq that would allow
the one to take over the entire area
with threats now so there's only one
problem there's nobody here disagreeing
with you right I'm thinking about two
signature achievements of the Obama
administration at first term one is
health care the other is the stimulus
they were both flawed perhaps he
shouldn't have allowed Congress to take
that he took a little bit more
leadership and not allowed the ben
nelsons and the lieberman's of the world
to dictate the process to the extent
that they did but I think and no I think
Nancy Pelosi was had a positive effect
on but I think those two meatheads
really hung it up in a bad way
I think he shouldn't have it I think he
shouldn't have included that tax cut in
the stimulus because I think it's an
effectual you give somebody 10 bucks a
week they buy a mountain Dew in a pack
of cigarettes and I don't know that it
goes that far I think it should do that
so your dear point about our rent I must
say when I watched your picture of the
other night I kind of Argo opening now
[Laughter]
with the economy be better I don't know
this rock talk was about and when he got
his way for the first two years
unemployment rates sales up above 10%
it's only when Republicans stop blocking
any more of this crap but it's slowly
starting to help the Obama care so much
I mean look no Abama care is keeping
people out of work care was popular in a
bipartisan way so everyone went through
health care maybe it was a mistake not
to pivot immediately over to jobs but
you know you nobody has nobody more on
the Republican side one in health care
we wanted Republicans conniving lip
service
Bhama care no title of the bill was a
portable Health Care Act and the problem
is although it's affordable if the
government pays for it for you nothing
drove down the cost of health care our
crisis in America is a true that our
health care that Sorrels money spent our
health care cost us twice with the
Canadians really know why don't we have
the Canadian health care
[Applause]
health care clinics in Montana go ahead
and continue the experiment that's fine
the fact is though we haven't driven
down the cost of delivery of healthcare
yet the larger the vibrations in America
are using exactly the same technique as
we're using in Montana and we have a we
have a contract but there's a 100
million dollar savings okay Ann Coulter
how could Obama be any stronger on
foreign policy short of attacking Iran
and I remember you said after 9/11 what
we should do is attack Muslim countries
kill their leaders and convert them to
Christianity yeah you still you still
stand by that since you love George Bush
so much I want to go back to that and
for one thing van i loved the invitation
but I do have to correct you on one
thing that memo bin Laden determined to
attack I keep printing it in my books
because no one everyone is determined
not to read it the argument was they
said it's gonna be bombs around federal
buildings we would have had bomb
sniffing dogs around federal buildings
in New York it's literally they were
smart nuts and looking for that what
happened well been long determines
attack is like actress determined to
succeed in Hollywood yeah we know he was
the turtle have any intelligence well
actually that was at the end of a long
memo trail there was a lot leading up to
in fact that was the one they put out
because they could not get Bush to CIA
could not get Bush to focus before he
was elected but just don't sign the
rights didn't know what al Qaeda was
before she got out to investigate not
investigate what I would investigate is
Norman Mineta making us all have fingers
stuck up our butts to go through airport
security that's just you know
[Applause]
look like a terrorist TSA in 2003 2004
was about 12,000 and the lines were kind
of like they are today they're now at
67,000 what did you get for that many
people I couldn't agree that's what the
terrorists did to us they did 9/11 and
we all know that terrible tragedy but
what they really did I just did this
movie was a period movie and I went and
had to use special effects to take out
9/11 steel boundaries and cement columns
everywhere all over the country that's
what they did to us they [ __ ] us again
where we did the Patriot Act so that
neighbors were spying on neighbors they
tried to force every state to have a
real IV so that they could track when
you got on a plane where you went and
how you got home so they could track
every single citizen that's what they
did take away our civilians bloated
opaque homeland security apparatus
that's where all Bush's jobs went to
Bush's jobs went to government jobs
he lost private sector jobs on my right
jet the life expertise so we're against
it what I said I know and I believe
darrell Issa were against it the
Homeland Security Department that if you
take a whole bunch of failed
organizations and put them all together
they metastasize
they're supposed to be against yes I
know and your point is good governor why
our Committee on a bipartisan you're
getting nicer no ours no this story is a
sad story I was a freshman on judiciary
and on a bipartisan basis Bob Barr
Barney Frank a whole group of us worked
out and voted sixteen separate
amendments to dial back the Patriot Act
to what was temporarily quote needed and
then we got rolled on the floor so at
the end of the day it was it easy to
vote no on something called the Patriot
Act no do I regret that I didn't scream
bloody murder again and again for the
fact that the Bush administration let
law enforcement get a whole bunch of
things they always wanted that had
nothing to do with terrorism had
everything to do with what law
enforcement in wanted for years of
course I do so does every American on
either side who realize oh we can we
gave her the ones but this was a real
loss it was that we can all agree I
think we can all agree what we need to
do is invade Muslim countries kill their
leaders
Real Time with Bill Maher Friday night
at 10:00 ask bill and his guests to a
questions right after the show at
hbo.com